how crazy are sweeties DMS these days
like do you like like listen message
requests do you even open them like you
know how you could like you get your DMs
that you see right away and then there's
like just anybody can throw a DM at you
do you ever just go through and see if
like
fans hit you up or you know I'm sure
you're getting random D picks just in
and out of that thing you know what I
appreciate now
um Instagram blurs the picture they do
and if you know what
if you're paying close attention yeah
you can see the outline of it so I don't
even open it because it'd be blurred out
it should be like that that looks like a
blurry dick
and what's up with with Instagram
allowing all these porn pages to to tag
and like the tag photos
I guess you go to a lot of celebrities
tags it's like a whole bunch of porn I
didn't know they had porn on IG it's
it'd be all up in my text and I'm like
how is Instagram allowing this because
Twitter's Wild
what's your algorithm like oh no it's
better okay I cleaned it up I cleaned it
up it was it for a while though it was
[ __ ] up okay because like you know
I've had Twitter since 09 I used to
follow a bunch of porn chicks whatever
but it got to the point where like
it was like Russian Roulette if I opened
my laptop in front of my wife or kids
so I can't open my laptop and if I just
go to Twitter like man you just never
know what the [ __ ] gonna pop up the
algorithm so I had to unfollow hello
people it was not even the algorithm it
was just I was following you know a
bunch of sick [ __ ] and um but what's
crazy though is like my friends are
terrible like sick [ __ ] and if they
like something on Twitter it pops up in
my feed damn so if like likes some sick
[ __ ] on some which I'll be liking now
don't listen to him he we won't talk
about his internet history
hahaha
this man right here he you know he's my
producer he edits all my videos right so
we have a laptop for the bootleg head
podcast and it's signed into my gmail oh
so
I'm on my phone and I look up
Google right and and it has my Google
search history and the last thing I
searched
let's just say was some wild [ __ ] and
I'm like what the [ __ ]
I'm like I know I didn't look that up
and then I was like oh
so I called him and I said hey dude if
you're gonna look up porn make sure it's
not while you're logged into my [ __ ]
Gmail
you know what the worst though is is one
like
you know on your phone how you can swipe
out of things like let's say you forgot
to lock like whatever let's say it's
Twitter and whatever was last on your
Twitter is still up okay it's like some
wild [ __ ] so you think you're on your
phone everything's like moving how it's
supposed to and then he goes to the app
it's like the worst when you're like
around a lot of people oh yeah you know
that happens to me at an award show what
what wait what happened
I have some wild [ __ ] on my phone and I
opened it and I almost like
through my phone in the air because I
was so embarrassed I was like everybody
wait what was on your phone was it porn
I can't tell you that was it like was it
like some some smuts some nasty stuff
some risky [ __ ] some risky [ __ ] some
risky [ __ ] some blur dicks it was more
than that Jesus
was it like personal material or like
stuff online I'm just gonna keep coming
to myself